- Welcome back everybody.
We have run out of time,
but there's just enough left
for one last great story.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So earlier we had, somebody
in here is a soprano,
and they were like, wow!
Y'all can hear it.
Earlier, I like it, vocals.
Earlier, we had Giada De
Laurentiis on the show,
and she's one of the most
successful chefs on television,
but hot on her heels is a
little girl from Florida
who hopes to follow in her footsteps.
At nine-years-old,
she's already selling her homemade gnocchi
and get this, she's a published
author, so no big deal.
(audience clapping)
Let's get this little chef in here.
Say hi to Sadie, watching
on WESH 2 News at 3.
(audience cheering)
Hello.
How you doing, Sadie?
I hear cooking runs in your family.
- Yes, it does.
My Gigi used to make gnocchi
and that's how we all
learned how to make gnocchi.
I even started my own business
called Sadie's Gnocchis.
I sell gnocchi locally.
I even sell gnocchi to
my teachers at my school.
My goal is to be a chef like Giada.
- Oh, I love that.
Well, tell us about the book.
There's a reason you wrote it, right?
- Yes.
My book is called "Sadie's Journey:
How a Young Girl Cooks Her Way to Italy."
It's on Amazon now.
I wrote it
because I want another way
to earn money to go to Italy.
I also wrote it so kids my age
could know that they can do anything too.
- I love that.
Sadie, you're so rock and
roll for such a young lady.
I love you so much.
I'm liking your post right now.
I hope you get to Italy.
(audience clapping)
- [Sadie] Thank you.
- All right, and that's not all, Sadie.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
are inspired by your
writing and want to help you
with your goal of reaching Italy.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 to help out.
(audience cheering)
- Yay!
Thank you so much.
- I love it.
I can see your legs kicking.
All right, thank you so much, Sadie.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Mindy Kaling, Dove Cameron,
Giada De Laurentiis,
Chris Culver and Noah Kahan.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.